Listen, I think you two are going to be great at this. Is this your first podcast, the both of you? Sean, well? Yeah. Just the first time out. Yeah, first time out. What do we need to know? Well, you just go ahead and talk into that big foamy black thing in front of your lips.
听着，我觉得你们俩肯定能把这个节目做好。你们俩是第一次做播客吗？Sean，是吗？对。就是第一次尝试。对，第一次尝试。我们得知道些什么？哦，你只需要对着嘴巴前面那个又大又多泡沫的黑色家伙说话就行了。
And what do I do with my microphone? My microphone. Oh, wow. Welcome to Smartless. Smart. Lattice. Smart. Lattice. Smart. Lattice. Good morning, good day, good evening, listener.
那我该怎么用我的麦克风？我的麦克风。哦，哇。欢迎来到 SmartLess。Smart。Lattice。Smart。Lattice。Smart。Lattice。早上好，中午好，晚上好，听众朋友们。
We had a real robust in-house, smartless text chain going this morning. Yeah, that's right. It's fascinating. I love talking about that stuff. Talking about all the scary stuff. robust in-house smart list text chain going this morning. That's right. It's fascinating. I love talking about that stuff. Talking about all the scary stuff. On and on in the world.
今天早上我们内部有一个非常活跃的 SmartLess 短信聊天群。没错，太迷人了。我喜欢谈论那些事。谈论所有那些可怕的事。今天早上有个很活跃的内部 SmartLess 短信群。没错，太迷人了。我喜欢谈论那些事。谈论世界上所有那些可怕的事，没完没了。
Like AI, I don't know if you've heard about this, the acronym is AI, it stands for artificial intelligence. Wait, go back. And it's coming and it's going to be freaky. I wish the listeners could see how dead your eyes were when you were rolling that out. Shut up, Will, this is serious. No, it's coming.
比如人工智能，我不知道你们有没有听说过，缩写是 AI，代表人工智能。等等，倒回去。它正在到来，而且会变得非常诡异。我真希望听众们能看到你刚才说这话时眼神有多死寂。闭嘴，Will，这是认真的。不，它真的要来了。
So what now? I'm running for the hills by a pistol, what are we doing? Or I guess double down on just chatting with folks like we're doing. I guess you can kind of robot us, can't you? I mean, I'm pretty much all the way. You've always called me a robot, Will. There is no way, Jason. It's me, Will. I'm here.
那现在怎么办？我得拿着手枪逃到山里去吗，我们在干什么？或者我猜就是加倍和大家聊天，就像我们现在这样。我猜你基本上可以把我们做成机器人，对吧？我是说，我基本上已经完全……你一直叫我机器人，Will。绝对不可能，Jason。是我，Will。我在这儿。
You look so good today. It is a pleasure to be on Smarla's. I'm excited for our next guest. Wait, do I have any good dad jokes? Are you going to try to lighten things? Yeah, I got one any good dad jokes? Are you going to try to lighten things? What do you call a teacher who never farts in public? What's that?
你今天气色真好。很高兴能来 SmartLess。我很期待我们的下一位嘉宾。等等，我有什么好笑的冷笑话吗？你打算缓和一下气氛吗？对，我有一个有什么好笑的冷笑话？你打算缓和一下气氛吗？你管一个从不在公众面前放屁的老师叫什么？什么？
Oh my goodness, Sean. Sean, that's really fun. That is fun. I've taken that one. I'm going to ride that for a week. I know how that feels. I was going to say, speaking of which... No, Sean, do you have a callback today or a photo shoot or something? Because you do look great. Oh, thanks, yeah. What's the occasion? I took a shower and this is what it looks like. Yeah. There we have it. Wow.'t, I took a shower and this is what it looks like.
哦天哪，Sean。Sean，这真的很好笑。真有意思。我记住这个了。我要用这梗聊一个星期。我懂那种感觉。我正想说，说到这个……不，Sean，你今天有试镜回访、拍写真还是别的什么吗？因为你今天看起来确实状态很好。哦，谢谢，是的。是什么风把你吹来的？我洗了个澡，它看起来就是这样。好吧。这就是真相。哇。没有，我洗了个澡，它看起来就是这样。
Yeah. There we have it. Wow. Yeah, I took a shower. Now when you shower, do you shampoo your hair and condition it? I don't condition it, I've never conditioned my hair. I just shampoo.
好吧。这就是真相。哇。对，我洗了个澡。那么你洗澡的时候，会用洗发水洗头并用护发素吗？我不用护发素，我从来没用过护发素。我只用洗发水。
Okay, and is it every time you take, every time you shower you shampoo your hair? Yeah, who doesn't? People who look good? I don't. What do you mean? Every time. Yeah, every time. You shampoo't. What do you mean? Every time. Yeah, every time.
好吧，那你每次洗澡，每次洗头都会用洗发水吗？对啊，谁不会？长得帅的人吗？我不会。什么意思？每次。对，每次。你不用吗？什么意思？每次。对，每次。
You shampoo your hair every time you shower, you get that fluffy shitty hairdo like Shum P. A. Yeah, and you're getting rid of the natural oils. Okay, you're washing away your natural oils. Well, I don't. You need some clump. Yeah, you need your natural oils. You need your natural clump.
你每次洗澡都用洗发水洗头，就会搞出那种蓬松、糟糕的发型，就像 Shum P. A. 一样。对，而且你在洗掉天然油脂。好吧，你在洗掉你的天然油脂。嗯，我没有。你需要一些发束感。对，你需要天然油脂。你需要自然的蓬松感。
Yeah, but what about... You gotta get Lorenzo's oil, okay? Yeah. That's what that movie was about, Lorenzo's oil. Do you know, can I reference one of my own projects, please? Thank you. That's what that movie was about, Lorenzo Zoyle. Do you know, can I reference one of my own projects, please? Thank you. Here we go.
对，但是……你得用 Lorenzo 的油，对吧？对。那部电影就是讲这个的，Lorenzo 的油。你知道吗，我能顺便宣传一下我自己的项目吗？谢谢。那部电影就是讲 Lorenzo Zoyle 的。你知道吗，我能顺便宣传一下我自己的项目吗？谢谢。来吧。
A picture called Paul, not widely seen, but I did play a secret service agent last name Zoyle. One of the last seeds of the movie, I finally introduced myself first name Lorenzo. Oh my God, first name Lorenzo. Oh my God, what a sweaty joke. And I was told by the director to... And you're right. No, it was actually Greg Mottola. Oh, Greg Mottola, right, yes, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
有一部叫《保罗》的电影，看的人不多，但我确实在里面演了一个特工，姓 Zoyle。电影的最后一个彩蛋里，我终于介绍自己的名字叫 Lorenzo。哦天哪，名字叫 Lorenzo。哦天哪，多么油腻的一个笑话。导演让我……你说得对。不，其实是 Greg Mottola。哦，Greg Mottola，对，没错，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉。
But it was you and... Yeah, he says, you know, I think it's the first time he's ever really heard this himself. So in other words, play a beat once you say, Detective Zoil, Lorenzo Zoil. And then play a beat of like, oh my God, that sounds like the movie. Like a little wink.
但那是你和……对，他说，你知道吧，我想这是他自己头一次真正听到这个。换句话说，等你说了“Zoil 探员，Lorenzo Zoil”之后，停顿一下。然后营造出一种“哦天哪，听起来就像那部电影”的感觉。就像一个小暗示。
And so it was funny. I do recommend a rental on that. Paul, it's called? It's called Paul. Seth Rogen plays an alien in Hergivoresis. I'd look for like a free stream maybe. You know what I mean? Try five minutes of free and then go ahead and rent.
所以挺搞笑的。我确实推荐租来看看。叫《保罗》？片名叫《保罗》。Seth Rogen 在里面给一个外星人配音，还有 Hergivoresis。我可能会去找找有没有免费在线播放的吧。你知道我的意思吗？先试看五分钟免费的，然后再去租。
I'd get on a VPN and stream illegally. If it's $2.99, I'll buy it. What else? Okay, I'm back in Atlanta. I'm in my final week here. Are you so excited? You guys are in Los Angeles. I'm very excited.
我会用 VPN 非法盗版串流。如果只要 2.99 美元，我就会买。还有呢？好吧，我回亚特兰大。我这周是最后一周了。你是不是很激动？你们在洛杉矶。我非常激动。
I'm very excited to be done. It's been a great project, but I am excited to come home, see you folks again. When are you done? Saturday? I'm done on Sunday. Today's Wednesday. Sunday? I'm flying home Sunday too. I'm leaving today, but I'll be back Sunday.
我要解放了，我超级兴奋。这是一个很棒的项目，但我很高兴能回家，再次见到你们大家。你什么时候结束？周六？我周天结束。今天是周三。周天？我周天也飞回家。我今天走，但我周天会回来。
Wait, you're in Los Angeles. I'm in LA, but I'm going to New York today for a few days. And then you're going to be back on Sunday. I'll be back Sunday. I'll be back in the, after midnight. Oh, I'm glad we're caught up in the schedules. Wait, oh, so you're not coming back to- That is so shitty, Sean.
等等，你在洛杉矶。我在洛杉矶，不过我今天要动身去纽约待几天。然后你周天回来。我周天回来。我会在午夜过后回来。哦，很高兴我们的日程总算同步了。等等，哦，所以你不是要回——这太逊了，Sean。
God, Sean, that's so biting. So rude. I know, it's so judgy. Biting. So listen, what about Sunday? Were you there, Jay, or just Will? Just me. Oh, where?
天哪，Sean，太刻薄了。太粗鲁了。我知道，太爱评头论足了。刻薄。听着，那周天呢？你去没去，Jay，还是只有 Will？只有我。哦，去哪儿？
I thought you went to Sunday Funday. Sunday Funday. You were not there I guess Sean. I couldn't go. We had a very robust conversation, actually kind of about a lot of the stuff we were talking about this morning. We were talking about AI,
我还以为你去了“周日狂欢日”。周日狂欢日。我猜你不在，Sean。我没去。我们进行了一次非常深入的交流，实际上聊了很多我们今天早上讨论过的内容。我们在聊人工智能，
and we were talking about the future. But did you discuss? The present, we discussed the fact that we're all human. No, oh for, on Sunday Scotty rented a boat, we went out to the ocean and the boat, he finally got to his notes. Well, he managed to wedge his little talk notes in. Oh, really?
我们还在聊未来。但你们讨论了吗？现在，我们讨论了我们都是人类这个事实。不，哦，天哪，周日 Scotty 租了艘船，我们出海了，他在船上终于讲到他的备忘录了。好吧，他总算把他的那些小谈话备忘录塞进去了。哦，真的吗？
Doesn't that sound like a focus feature? Doesn't that sound like a little indie film? Scotty rented a boat. You know what I mean? To go in companion with Paul. Did he make it back home or are they still searching for him? We all were were gonna go. You guys used to have a boat though,
听起来是不是像个聚焦专题片？听起来是不是像个小众独立电影？Scotty 租了艘船。你知道我的意思吗？和《保罗》凑成一对。他是安全回到家了，还是大家还在搜救他？我们本来都打算去的。你们以前倒是有艘船，
so you've towing around with maybe getting another one? Mm, I don't know, maybe. Does Scotty pilot the boat? Well, he did this one for a little bit, but it had a captain, yeah, it had a little captain. But he likes to get behind the, does he wear a little cap? Yeah, you know, he doesn't wear a little cap, but he likes to drive big machinery.
所以你们在考虑要不要再买一艘？唔，我不知道，也许吧。Scotty 会开船吗？嗯，这艘船他开了一小会儿，但它有个船长，对，有个小船长。但他喜欢坐到……他会戴个小帽子吗？对，你知道的，他倒不戴小帽子，但他喜欢驾驶大机械。
So for one birthday one year. That's a joke here. Well, he's with the wrong guy. I mean, I don't know. Ba-da-ba-da-ba-da-ba-da-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba. He, for his birthday one year, we went to Vegas, because I knew that, and in Vegas, there's a place that you can go
所以有一年的生日。这里有个笑话。好吧，他找错人了。我是说，我不知道。巴达巴达巴达……他有一年的生日，我们去了拉斯维加斯，因为我知道，在拉斯维加斯有个地方，你可以去
where you can drive bulldozers and like, you can like Excavate land because I've done that or will have you ever done that I've done that it's it's Incredible driving those big things. Yeah, right never driven an excavator, but I drove like a big here comes an ad for GMC Get ready work. Well, well GMC trucks are professional grade. Are they so if you're working your way around? What happens at the Denali? Well, the Denali HD, or are you talking about the new Sierra EV?
开推土机，还可以像……你可以去挖掘土地，因为我干过那事，或者 Will 你干过吗？我干过，太不可思议了，开那些大块头。对，没错，从来没开过挖掘机，但我开过大……GMC 的广告要来啦。准备好干活吧。嗯，GMC 卡车是专业级的。是吗？所以如果你在工作时……Denali 会发生什么？好吧，Denali HD，还是你在说新款 Sierra EV？
Oh, God. So Sean, how was the Vegas trip? That was a while ago. We drove trucks, and what else did we do? Did you win any money? By the way, he's just doing a lot of things, driving the boats, and then going and driving the trucks. It's all just different characters from the village people.
哦，天哪。所以 Sean，拉斯维加斯之行怎么样？那是前一阵子的事了。我们开了卡车，还做了什么？你赢钱了吗？顺便说一句，他就是做了很多事，开船，然后去开卡车。这全都是“村夫合唱团”里的不同角色。
If I'm right. If I'm right. I mean. I mean. Any ride alongs for the cop outfit? What did they? Clearly he's not doing a lot of working or are you? No, these are the things.
如果我没猜错的话。如果我没猜错的话。我是说。我是说。有谁坐过警察服装的顺风车吗？他们干了什么？很显然他没怎么干活，还是说你在干？不，这些都是事情。
Either way, you're listening to this podcast and you're in a truck or you're working somewhere and you're like, these fucking Hollywood elite assholes. What are you talking about? Anybody can rent a boat and anybody can in a truck or you're working somewhere and you're like, these fucking Hollywood elite assholes. What are you talking about? Anybody can rent a boat and anybody can rent a... I'm going to Vegas to make believe I'm driving a tractor. People aren't renting boats, Sean.
不管怎样，当你听这个播客的时候，你正坐在卡车里，或者你在某个地方工作，然后你会想：这些该死的好莱坞精英混蛋。你在说什么？任何人都可以租条船，任何人都可以坐在卡车里，或者你在某个地方工作，然后你会想：这些该死的好莱坞精英混蛋。你在说什么？任何人都可以租条船，任何人都可以租个……我要去拉斯维加斯假装我在开拖拉机。人们才不租船呢，Sean。
You can buy a wife of like 100 bucks to go drive these things in Vegas. You're so fucking out of touch, dude. You're so out of touch. I was thinking, I was coming back home, I was at 45,000 feet and I was coming home and I was thinking about how out of touch. Sean. You're looking out the windshield I was at 45,000 feet and I was coming home and I was thinking about how out of touch Sean's.
你花 100 块钱就能在拉斯维加斯租个老婆去开这些大块头。你太特么不接地气了，老兄。你太脱离群众了。我当时在想，我在回家的路上，身处 45000 英尺的高空，我在回家的路上，心想 Sean 是多么脱离群众。Sean。你透过挡风玻璃往外看，越过飞行员。
You're looking out the windshield to the, past the pilot. I literally just spit out my teeth. Oh my God, that came out of my mouth. You know Sean, I would say though, I would like to, I actually, upon further reflection, Scotty would look good like a little sailor outfit. Sure he would.
我字面意思地把假牙都喷出来了。哦天哪，那东西从我嘴里飞出来了。你知道吗 Sean，不过我想说，我其实——经过进一步反思，Scotty 穿上一套水手服一定很好看。那是肯定的。
I'm just saying like an old school. All right, I'm making that up. Can we make that happen? Yes, we can make it happen. You can wear like a striped nautical. You know like the bib thing that goes on the back? No shirt, no shirt. Tits just resting over the top. And then here comes Sean in a little Gilligan outfit.
我只是说那种老派的。好吧，我瞎编的。能把它变成现实吗？可以，我们可以把它变成现实。你可以穿那种条纹海军风的……你知道背后有围兜的那种衣服吗？不穿衬衫，不穿衬衫。胸部直接露在外面。然后 Sean 穿着一套吉利根的小衣服出场了。
Hey! Don't say it. You guys should go as the skipper in Gilligan for Halloween. Oh my God. That's really funny. You guys, that would be so. Oh my God.
嘿！别这么说。万圣节你们俩可以扮成《吉利根岛》里的船长。哦天哪。太搞笑了。你们俩，那会非常……哦天哪。
And we'll be Marianne and Ginger? Come on, Willie. That's really funny. The professor and Marianne. All right, let's wake up our guest. I'm sure he's completely passed out by now. Guys, I'm very excited slash nervous for today's guest because I've always wanted to meet him.
那我们演玛丽安和金吉尔？得了吧，Will。太好笑了。教授和玛丽安。好了，让我们把我们的嘉宾叫醒吧。我敢肯定他现在已经完全不省人事了。伙计们，我对今天的嘉宾感到非常兴奋兼紧张，因为我一直想见他。
It's for quite a while now. Okay. He first hit my radar coming out of the Royal Academy of Dramatic Arts in 2012. What? Then he quickly became the lead in a very stylish action franchise. I can't mention because you know who he is.
已经好一阵子了。好啦。他 2012 年从皇家戏剧艺术学院毕业时，首次进入我的视线。什么？随后他迅速成了一个非常时髦的动作系列电影的男主角。我不能说名字，因为你们知道他是谁。
He voiced one of the most successful animated films. He went on to play one of the most iconic musicians of our time, was nominated and won all kinds of awards for that. Did we text about him today? Sorry. I'm going to go back to the top now. No, no, no, please don't. He has done and is doing a slew of cool stuff since then,
他给最成功的动画电影之一配过音。后来他饰演了我们时代最具标志性的音乐家之一，并因此获得并赢得了各种奖项。我们今天发短信聊过他了吗？抱歉。我从头开始说起行吗？不，不，不，请不要。他从那以后做过也正在做一堆酷炫的事情，
but most recently, this hot shot has knocked me down and out. Literally killed me. In the incredibly satisfying and remarkably successful Netflix film called Carry On. Guys, please say hello to Taron Egerton. Oh, Taron Egerton! Hey! You guys didn't know. You thought, there's no way he knows him
但最近，这个后起之秀把我给击倒了。字面意思地杀了我。在那部令人极度满意且极其成功的 Netflix 电影《携手登机》中。伙计们，请欢迎 Taron Egerton。哦，Taron Egerton！嘿！你们压根不知道。你们以为，他绝不可能认识他，
because he says he's looking forward to meeting him and then I switched it and I tricked you. That was a good mystery. There's less of a red herring and more of a lie. You know what I mean? Yeah, but fun. Fun to lie. My sister loves that movie, Taron. No way!
因为他说他很期待见到他，然后我来了个反转，把你们给骗了。这是个很好的悬念。与其说是红鲱鱼，不如说是个谎言。你知道我的意思吗？对，但很好玩。撒谎真好玩。我妹妹超喜欢那部电影，Taron。不会吧！
Carry on, carry on. No, which is Taron? Great film, great film. Great bad guy in that. Let Taron talk. Good morning, Taron. Hi, Taron. Hi, Taron.
《携手登机》，《携手登机》。不是，哪一部 Taron？好片，好片。里面的反派演得真好。让 Taron 说两句。早啊，Taron。嗨，Taron。嗨，Taron。
Good day. How are you guys? Thanks so much for having me on. Very excited you're here. We're very honored to have you. Oh, it's lovely. It's nice to see you, Jason. You good?
你好。你们好吗？非常感谢邀请我来。很高兴你能来。我们非常荣幸你能来。哦，太棒了。很高兴见到你，Jason。你还好吗？
Good to see you. I love the shaved head. Listener, he's got a real tight, like a swim team almost, marine type of shaved head. I've done it twice and I loved it. That's it, streamlined, yeah. Oh, it's so good. Get into where I'm going quicker.
很高兴见到你。我喜欢这个光头。听众朋友们，他留着一个非常干净利落的、几乎像游泳队或海军似的光头。我理过两次，我超喜欢。就是这样，很流线型，对。哦，太棒了。让我更快融入我要去的地方。
I just finished a movie where I had a kind of shaved head, so it's still growing out, yeah. So you're keeping it? I think so, for now, yeah, for now. Through the summer, because it's warm. Although it doesn't get that warm when I grow it out anymore. I'm not blessed like you guys are. Well, yeah, for now. Through the summer, because it's warm. Although it doesn't get that warm when I grow it out anymore. I'm not blessed like you guys are. You guys have got three very fine heads of hair.
我刚拍完一部电影，里面留着类似的光头，所以现在还在慢慢长出来，对。所以你打算留着？我想是的，目前是的，先留着。整个夏天都留着，因为比较凉爽——虽然头发长出来后，对我来说也不是那么热。我可没有你们那么有福气。好吧，对，目前是的。整个夏天都留着，因为比较凉爽——虽然头发长出来后，对我来说也不是那么热。我可没有你们那么有福气。你们三位的头发都长得极好。
No, it's all fake. You don't want to see me take it off. It's all snapped on, glued. Now where do we find you? You're in Los Angeles? No, I'm not. I'm in Wales. I got back from Australia a couple of weeks ago where I just finished the film and I've come home to see my family. So I'm here for two weeks before.
不，全都是假的。你可不想看我摘下来的样子。全都是粘上去的、胶水粘的。现在我们在哪儿能找到你？你在洛杉矶吗？不，我不在。我在威尔士。我几周前从澳大利亚回来，我在那儿刚拍完一部电影，然后我回家看望我的家人。所以我在这儿呆两周，然后……
I've got questions about Wales. You know, we're kind of friendly with Gareth Bale. Wales' own Gareth Bale listener. A celebrated son of Wales. Celebrated. Very celebrated. And you've had Matthew Reese on the podcast before I listened to that episode.
我对威尔士有问题要问。你知道的，我们跟 Gareth Bale 挺熟的。听众朋友们，那是威尔士自己的 Gareth Bale。一位备受赞誉的威尔士之子。备受赞誉。非常备受赞誉。你之前在播客里请过 Matthew Rhys，我听过那一集。
We've had a few very distinguished and now we've rounded it out. We've had the most distinguished Welshman alive, I think. Sweet Willy's done some time there in Wales, haven't you? I wouldn't call it done some time. I was able to enjoy some time in Wales for a few months, many years back, in Cardiff. Beautiful country, man, beautiful. Yeah, it's gorgeous. So I'm from Aberystwyth,
我们请过几位非常杰出的嘉宾，现在我们终于集齐了。我觉得我们请到了活着的、最杰出的威尔士人。亲爱的 Willy 也在威尔士待过一段时间吧，对吧？我不会称之为“待过一段时间”。多年前，我在加的夫愉快地度过了几个月。美丽的国家，老兄，太美了。对，美极了。所以我是从阿伯里斯特威斯来的，
and it's a stunning part of the world. I'm further north, a couple of hours north. But when I finish a job, I like to come back and just decompress, spend time with my... Is that on the way to Snowdonia? Is that this, in that kind of... If you're coming from Cardiff, it is, yeah. It is right on the coast.
那是世界上风景绝美的一个地方。我住得更北一点，往北两小时的车程。但当我结束工作时，我喜欢回来放松一下，和我……那是去斯诺多尼亚的路上吗？是在那个方向吗……如果你从加的夫出发，是的。它就在海岸边。
Snowdonia is a place in Wales? Yeah. coast. Snowdonia is a place in Wales? Yeah. Wow. Snowdonia is a place in Wales. And the mountain at the center of that area is called Snowdon. And I think it might be the third or second highest peak in the UK, I think. Sounds like a game of thrones. Which would make it a good 60 or 70 feet tall.
斯诺多尼亚是威尔士的一个地方吗？对。海岸边。斯诺多尼亚是威尔士的一个地方吗？对。哇。斯诺多尼亚是威尔士的一个地方。那片区域中心的山叫做斯诺登山。我想它可能是英国第二或第三高的山峰，我觉得。听起来像《权力的游戏》。这使得它足足有 60 或 70 英尺高。
Yeah. Yes, exactly. Exactly. Now, tell me about what if you're a dummy like me and you're like, hey, I don't know whether I should go to England or I should go to Wales. God, that is you. What would be the biggest difference,
对。没错。没错。好了，告诉我，如果像我这样的笨蛋，想去英国或者威尔士旅游却不知道该去哪儿，天哪，这简直就是你。最大的区别会是什么？
and be careful here, because you're surrounded by Welsh. What's the big difference between Wales and England? What would be? Well, let's say there are quite distinct cultural differences. We have a language here that we still speak. Really? Yeah, in certain parts of the country, people speak Welsh, sometimes as a first language.
在这里说话可得小心点，因为你被威尔士人包围了。威尔士和英格兰之间最大的区别是什么？会是什么呢？嗯，怎么说呢，它们有着截然不同的文化差异。我们这里有一种至今仍在使用的语言。真的吗？对，在国家的某些地方，人们说威尔士语，有时甚至将其作为第一语言。
So you go to... It's not English? It's not English. It's Welsh. What's it sound like? It's much older than English, as I understand it, but it's filled with lots of very kind of throaty, guttural sounds.
所以你去……这不是英语？这不是英语。是威尔士语。听起来怎么样？据我所知，它比英语古老得多，里面包含了很多非常粗哑、从喉咙发出的声音。
Is it like Gaelic? You really didn't know, it's got a lot of consonants next to each other as well. Yeah, exactly. So it sounds more like Scots Gaelic or Irish Gaelic than English. Yeah, yeah. Can you give us just a little something? The one that I'm always asked to do is the village that I was raised in
有点像盖尔语吗？你还真不知道，它里面还有很多连在一起的辅音。对，没错。所以它听起来与其说是英语，倒不如说更像苏格兰盖尔语或爱尔兰盖尔语。对，对。能给我们稍微展示一下吗？我总是被要求表演的那个，是我长大的那个村庄的名字，
is the thing that I'm always asked to do on talk shows and things because I was raised in a village called Llanberkwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwik Wow. And then you get there and you bang a right. Yeah. Exactly. Wow. I wonder what that, what is it derived from? Like it sounds, it sounds almost German, but also real Nordic. Yeah. There are bits of, you see strange little crossovers between other languages in Europe. So there are things like, you'll just find odd words that are very similar, so German for rabbit is Kinninschen, and Welsh for rabbit is Cuningen. So there's like really strange little bits of crossover that you find.
这也是我在脱口秀节目和其他地方经常被要求表演的，因为我是在一个叫做 Llanberkwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwikwik... 的村庄长大的。哇。然后你到了那儿，往右一拐。对。没错。哇。我想知道那个，它是从什么演变来的？听起来，听起来有点像德语，但又很像北欧语。对。有些地方你会发现欧洲其他语言之间奇怪的小交叉。所以你会发现一些奇怪的词非常相似，比如德语里的兔子是 Kinninschen，而威尔士语里的兔子是 Cuningen。所以你会发现一些非常奇怪的小语种交集。
I gotcha. Wow. Is anything specific about your Welsh upbringing that has kind of shaped your perspective on your career, like managing kind of shaped your perspective on your career, like managing kind of the silliness and the nonsense sometimes that we all kind of enjoy slash navigate. Anything about your Welsh upbringing
我明白了。哇。你的威尔士成长经历中，有什么特别的东西塑造了你对职业生涯的看法吗？比如如何应付那些有时我们大家都很享受又不得不应付的愚蠢和胡闹。你的威尔士成长经历中有什么
that has specifically suited you for that? I think I'm from a fairly kind of, I'm not from a particularly affluent part of the world. I'm from a very normal town, quite blue collar as you'd probably say. And I come from a place where people are quite, I think quite down to earth, quite relatable and real. You know, a lot of my early adult life and the end of my teens was spent kind of, I don't know, we've got like the most pubs per square capita of anywhere in the country. Really? Really.
特别适合让你应对这一切的吗？我觉得我来自一个相当……我不是来自一个特别富裕的地方。我来自一个非常普通的城镇，正如你可能会说的，相当底层。我来自一个人们非常……我觉得非常脚踏实地、非常接地气、很真实的地方。你知道，我成年早期和青少年时期的末尾，基本上都在……我不知道，我们的酒吧人均密度是全国最高的。真的吗？真的。
And it's less now, but I remember when I was coming up, you'd still see groups of older gentlemen who'd kind of spontaneously break out into song and sing kind of, you know, lovely harmonies and things. We have a tradition of male voice choirs here in Wales, and that's something that I think has kind of seeped into who I am. Oh, that's interesting. Right, would that explain your ability to sing? I think in part, you know, most Welsh people have a go at some point, I think. We have choirs are a big part of school life, certainly in my at some point, I think. Choirs are a big part of school life, certainly in my experience anyway.
现在少了一些，但我记得我刚长大那会儿，你依然能看到一群年长的绅士，他们会突然情不自禁地唱起歌来，唱着那种……你知道的，优美的和声之类的。我们威尔士有男声合唱团的传统，我觉得这已经融入了我的骨血。哦，很有意思。对，这能解释你唱歌的能力吗？我觉得有一部分原因吧，你知道，大多数威尔士人觉得合适的时候都会试一试。合唱团是我们学校生活很大的一部分，至少在我的经历里……合唱团是我们学校生活很大的一部分，至少在我的经历里是这样的。
I think that's something that I've definitely carried forward into my life because I've done a couple of bits of singing. So then how did you come from this sort of small town in Wales, out in the rural area, if you will. Yes, the middle of nowhere, mate. Okay, so middle of nowhere, Wales, beautiful country, but middle of nowhere, and then you end up, and now you're a Terry and Edgerton movie star. long way to go. What was the first step in that, to sort of move from there in that direction? Well thank you. Thank you very much. That's very nice of you to say. But I, so it was a lot to do
我觉得这绝对是我带进生活里的一点，因为我也唱过几次歌。那么，你是怎么从威尔士这个小镇、郊区走出来的呢？是的，鸟不拉屎的地方，老兄。好吧，鸟不拉屎的威尔士，美丽的国家，但是鸟不拉屎的地方，然后你最终……现在你成了电影明星 Taron Egerton。这路程可真远。其中的第一步是什么，怎么从那个地方朝这个方向迈出步伐？谢谢。非常感谢。你这么说太好了。不过我……这跟
with the town I'm from actually. The town I'm from is called Aberystwyth and we have a great art center and I joined a youth theater there when I was 15. I moved from one part of Wales to another when I was 12, and I had a couple of years where I really struggled to acclimatize and make friends and meet new people. And I joined the Youth Theatre when I was 15, and it just felt like the universe clicked into place. I found my tribe, I felt like I had an attitude to something which wasn't a feeling I'd really had before.
我出生的城镇有很大关系。我老家叫阿伯里斯特威斯，那里有一个很棒的艺术中心，我 15 岁时加入了那里的青年剧团。我 12 岁时从威尔士的一个地方搬到了另一个地方，有两年的时间，我很难适应环境、结交朋友和认识新面孔。我 15 岁加入了青年剧团，感觉就像宇宙突然严丝合缝地对上了。我找到了我的同类，我感觉自己对某些事情有了热情，而这种感觉我以前从未有过。
Was that something, sorry to interrupt you, but was that something that like your parents were like, oh, poor Taron is not making friends and we keep moving around and maybe joining this theater group, honey, you'd meet some friends? Or was it a passion you had for acting? No, I don't, I think it was,
那是……抱歉打断你，那是你父母觉得“哦，可怜的 Taron 交不到朋友，我们搬来搬去，也许加入这个戏剧团，亲爱的，你能结交些朋友”这样的吗？还是说你对表演有着某种热情？不，我不觉得，我觉得是，
I think I just was watching other people do it from afar and started to get that itch and that craving. And I always, I think I always, even though, don't get me wrong, even though I was struggling to kind of acclimatize in a new place, I was still an insufferable attention seeking class clown. So it was like an appealing outlet for that I think. Can't relate.
我觉得我只是远远地看着别人表演，然后开始有了那种心痒难耐的渴望。而且我一直……我觉得我一直以来，虽然——别误会我，尽管我在努力适应新环境时遇到了困难，但我仍然是一个令人讨厌的、哗众取宠的班级小丑。所以我觉得这对我来说是一个很有吸引力的宣泄口。感同身受。
Yeah. You know, it's funny, Sean, it's not dissimilar. It's not dissimilar from you. I'm all bits aside, right? Oh, please expand. Oh, yeah. And what I was going to say was, it occurs to me, and this is nothing new, it's not breaking news,
你知道这很有趣，Sean，这其实挺像的。和你挺像的。抛开所有笑话不谈，对吧？哦，请展开说说。哦，是的。我想说的是，我突然意识到——这也不是什么新鲜事，也不是什么突发新闻，
but there is a recurring theme here that we hear from a lot of people, a lot of performers, of how many times people, when they're younger, join a local theater group, a local theater, whatever. And how important these things are in our communities for being an outlet, not just an outlet for kids, not as a conduit to superstardom, but just a place for kids who don't feel like they fit in
但这里有一个反复出现的主题，我们从很多人、很多表演者那里听到过：很多人在年轻时加入当地的戏剧团、社区剧场之类的地方，有多少次这种情况发生过。这些东西在我们的社区里有多么重要，它们不仅是孩子们的宣泄口，不是通往巨星之路的管道，而只是给那些觉得自己格格不入的孩子们提供一个地方，
to be able to go in to find their voice. And how often we hear it and how important that is and how much we need to protect that. Because it's one of the few, I think so too, I think it's one of the few places where it doesn't matter who you are, what color your skin is, who you are, your gender, anything at all, everybody's welcome.
让他们能够去那里找到自己的声音。我们是多么经常听到这种说法，这又是多么重要，我们又是多么需要保护它。因为我觉得这也是为数不多的几个地方之一，我觉得也是如此，这是为数不多的几个地方之一，在这里无论你是谁、你的肤色是什么、你的性别是什么、什么都不重要，每个人都受欢迎。
Team sports too. Team sports for sure. And sports too. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. So you joined this local youth theater and you find a place where you find your people as it were. Yeah, exactly. That's exactly what it felt like. I found my tribe and you know what ensued between the ages of 15 and 19 were just these really blissful years
团队运动也是。团队运动绝对是。体育也是。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。所以你加入了这个当地的青年剧团，找到了一个能找到志同道合的人的地方。对，没错。感觉确实如此。我找到了我的同类，你知道在 15 岁到 19 岁之间发生的事情，简直就是那些真正幸福的岁月，
of being really creative, really social, really out of my shell. And it was all kind of tied together through drama. So I was, you know, I was getting involved with Shakespeare plays and more contemporary stuff. And I just felt that I was in my groove, in my lane, really, really loved it. And by the time I was about 17, I knew that I wanted to go to drama school. And so I auditioned. And this ties back to me being the insufferable attention seeker. The first year I auditioned,
充满创造力、非常社交、完全打开了自己。这一切都通过戏剧紧密联系在一起。所以，我（你知道的）开始参与莎士比亚戏剧和更现代的作品。我真的觉得自己进入了状态，找到了自己的轨道，非常非常喜欢。到了我 17 岁左右的时候，我知道自己想去戏剧学校。于是我去参加了试镜。这又回到了我那个令人讨厌的、哗众取宠的性格。我第一年去试镜的时候，
I was rejected everywhere, and from the limited amount of feedback I got, they said that I was a little underprepared and maybe a little cocksure on myself, and that really, really took me down a couple of pegs. And the following year I went... But you took the note and recovered. I've gotten that note. it's debilitating.
到处都被拒绝了。从我得到的有限反馈来看，他们说我准备得有点不足，而且可能有点过于自信，这真的——真的狠狠打击了我好几次。第二年我去……但你听取了意见并恢复过来了。我也收到过那种评价。太折磨人了。
Yeah, yeah, I think so, I think so. Bubble pop. Was there a mentor in there, was there a person in that journey or multiple people who you can identify as people who encouraged you and pushed you the right way? Totally, there's so many people. I mean, the first people that spring to mind are my family. So at that time, we were still, we still rented the family home.
对，对，我想是的，我想是的。泡沫破裂了。那里面有什么导师吗？在你的这段旅程中，有没有一个人或多个人，你可以把他们视为鼓励你、推了你一把的贵人？完全有，有好多人。我的意思是，第一个浮现在脑海里的人就是我的家人。当时，我们仍然……我们租着自家的房子。
I've never wanted for anything growing up, but I'm not from an affluent background. And each audition for drama school cost somewhere in the region of 40 to 60 pounds. And my auntie paid for one, my father paid for one, my stepfather paid for one, my mother paid for one. And I paid for one. And it was a real family effort to get me to this handful of auditions. I'm picturing Charlie Babbitt
我从小到大没缺过什么东西，但我并非来自富裕背景。每一次戏剧学校的试镜费用大概在 40 到 60 英镑之间。我阿姨帮我付了一场，我爸爸帮我付了一场，我继父帮我付了一场，我妈妈帮我付了一场。我自己付了一场。为了让我去参加这寥寥几场试镜，全家人真的齐心协力。我在脑海里想象着查理·巴克特
in Charlie and Chocolate Factory. It was a lovely story. Totally in the same bed. It was a lovely scene. It was a lovely scene. It was all in the same bed. I love it. And then, yeah, the second year, it all came together and I got a few offers at different drama schools. And yeah, the rest is history.
在《查理和巧克力工厂》里的情景。这是一个动人的故事。完全挤在同一张床上。这是一幅温馨的画面。这是一个温馨的画面。大家全挤在同一张床上。我太喜欢了。然后，对，第二年，一切都顺利了，我在不同的戏剧学校拿到了几个录取通知。然后，是的，历史就这样诞生了。
What monologues did you do for your auditions? Do you remember? Well, weirdly, really weirdly, I was required to sing a song, and I did your song by Elton John and Bernie Thorpe. And then I did Edmund, The Nature of My Goddess, which is a kind of classic flashy villain turn from King Lear. And I actually can't remember what my modern piece was. But yeah.
你试镜的时候演了哪些独白？你还记得吗？嗯，说来也怪，真的很奇怪，当时要求我唱一首歌，我唱了埃尔顿·约翰和伯尼·托平的《你的歌》。然后我演了爱德蒙的《自然的女神》，那是《李尔王》中一个经典的、浮夸的反派高潮桥段。我其实记不得我的现代独白是什么了。不过，对。
That's so cool. And what was your growing up, first of all, two things. One is when you said you were singing and stuff. I have a little tidbit, I don't know if it's true. So now you're gonna say when he said your song, you're gonna say my song, like $5 foot long. That's wrong. Right, isn't that your song?
太酷了。那你成长过程中——首先，有两件事。第一件是，当你刚才说你唱歌什么的。我有个小八卦，不知道是不是真的。所以现在你听到他说“你的歌”时，你会说“我的歌”，就像五美元英尺长三明治那样。不对。对吧，那不是你的歌吗？
The subway. That's his anthem, not his song. $5 foot long. So no, one little tidbit, I don't know if it's true, but Irish dancing, have you ever seen Irish dancing when they don't- You're doing ankle slapping? Yeah, where they don't move the upper part of their body.
赛百味。那是他的宣传标语，不是他的歌。五美元英尺长三明治。好吧，还有一个小八卦，我不知道是不是真的，爱尔兰踢踏舞，你们看过爱尔兰舞蹈吗，当他们不——你在做拍脚踝的动作？对，就是他们上半身一动不动。
They don't move the upper part of their body. Do you know why? Why? Because, I don't know if this is true, but in Ireland, dancing used to be against the law or something like that, and so the police used to walk by the pubs, and so they didn't see the upper part of their body moving. They would just move the bottom part of their legs.
他们的上半身一动不动。你知道为什么吗？为什么？因为——我不知道是不是真的——在爱尔兰，跳舞以前是违法的之类的，所以警察经常从酒吧外面走过，为了不让警察看到他们上半身在动。他们就只动下半截腿。
And that's how I, that's what I heard. God, I hope it's not. What do you mean you heard? On what website are you diving into? When did you hear that? I heard that growing up, because I'm Irish. Can we just, can we just blub in conjecture wherever we want now? Can we just sort of like...
这就是我……我听说的是这个。天哪，希望这不是真的。什么叫你听说？你在哪个网站上冲浪看到的？你什么时候听说的？我从小就听说，因为我是爱尔兰人。难道我们现在可以随心所欲地瞎编猜测了吗？难道我们可以像……
I asked Chad to be cheeky. That's, I mean... I don't know if that's true. If that's true, that's one of the dumbest things I've ever heard in my life. No, but isn't that interesting? It makes sense, because they don't move your upper body. Your upper body's stiff.
我问 Chad 只是为了好玩。那是，我是说……我不知道这是不是真的。如果这是真的，那绝对是我这辈子听过最蠢的事情之一。不，但这难道不有趣吗？这说得通，因为他们确实不动上半身。你的上半身是僵硬的。
No, we get why. And because there's windows that only go down to waist height throughout Ireland. We understand. I hope it's not true. God, I hope it's not true and that you've been saying this forever. All right, so Taron. Why don't you read a book?
不，我们懂为什么。因为爱尔兰到处都是只开到腰部高度的窗户。我们懂的。我希望这不是真的。天哪，我希望这不是真的，而且你居然一直在说这个。好吧，Taron。你为什么不去看本书呢？
So the other thing is, what was your view from Wales? What was your impression of America? And was that different than when you actually arrived? How early did you see Will and Grace and did that inspire you to make the trip across the Atlantic? It's a huge part of my formative years. I did, I enjoyed that show very much. Thank you, thank you.
另一件事是，你对威尔士的视角是怎样的？你对美国的印象是什么？这和你真正到达美国时有什么不同？你有多早就看了《威尔和格蕾丝》，这有没有激发你开启横跨大西洋的旅程？这是我成长岁月中非常重要的一部分。我看过，我非常喜欢那个节目。谢谢，谢谢。
I mean it was like, you know, certainly when I started acting, the perception of America is like, I don't know, I suppose the land of plenty, I guess. And was that always the destination? No, absolutely not, no. When I went to drama school, I thought, I thought I'm going to be a theater actor, and I thought I will get a couple of guest spots
我的意思是，你知道的，至少在我开始演戏的时候，对美国的印象就像是——我不知道，我想象中是个物产丰富的地方吧。那一直都是你的目的地吗？不，绝对不是，完全不是。我去戏剧学校的时候心想，我以后要当个戏剧演员，我想我会去电视上客串几个角色，
on the telly and that will pay my rent, will pay the mortgage. And I really mean that. It was a shock when films happened. So that was the adult, that was the life goal, the adult, the occupation, sort of career goal was I'm going to be a working actor in the theater. And a guest spot here or there on television
这样就能付房租、付房贷了。我是认真的。当电影的机会降临时，我感到很震惊。所以那才是成年后的生活目标，成年后的职业、某种职业目标就是：我要成为一名戏剧界的常驻演员。偶尔在电视上客串一把
will subsidize, yeah. Keep the lights on. Yeah, I mean that would be incredible. That was the dream. subsidize. on the TV and it was like a mind-blowing thing. Yeah, the West End, you know, the West End. I remember I did a summer season production of Oliver when I was about 14, 15, and they had actors come up from London to play the adult roles. And they were, you know, actors who'd been on the West End.
补贴一下家用，对吧。维持生计。对，我的意思是那太不可思议了。那就是梦想。补贴家用。在电视上客串，那简直是个大开眼界的经历。对，伦敦西区，你知道的，西区。我记得我大概 14、15 岁时演过一个夏天季度的《雾都孤儿》，他们找了伦敦的演员来演成年人的角色。他们是……你知道的，都是在西区演过戏的演员。
And it was like, you know, it was like Humphrey Bogart had just stepped into our history. It was that level of kind of grandeur. And for Tracy, the West End is the London version of Broadway, just so my sense is. Exactly. So then Taron, was there enough time for you to be comfortable with where you are today?
那种感觉就像……就像亨弗莱·鲍嘉走进了我们的历史课。就是那种级别的宏大。对于 Tracy 来说，西区就是百老汇的伦敦版，我这么理解没错吧。完全正确。那么 Taron，你有足够的时间去适应你今天的成就吗？
Because, dude, are you even 30? Like you're not- I am, I'm 35. Okay, so then the amount of time- You look great. That's not enough, that's not a lot. It's not enough. Thanks, man.
因为，老兄，你满 30 岁了吗？感觉你还没——我满了，我 35 岁了。好吧，那么这段时间……你看起来状态真好。那可不够，那时间不长。那可远远不够。谢啦，老兄。
Like, you know, what is it? It's like 15 years, I think, somewhere in that ballpark. Yeah, and you know what? I think there are times where, there are, it's like, with the attention that comes with success, as you will have all experienced, there are days when you're really, really good at dealing with it, and there are days where you feel robust enough to be available to everybody who comes up to you and asks for a photo or wants to have a conversation with you or asks
就像，你知道的，这算什么？大概 15 年吧，我觉得大概在这个范围。对，你知道吗？我觉得有时候，伴随着成功而来的关注，正如你们所有人所经历的那样，有些日子你非常非常擅长应付这一切，而有些日子你会觉得自己状态足够好、精力充沛，可以面对任何走过来向你要合影、想跟你聊天、或者问
if you'll record a bit for their daughter's 16th birthday. And then of course, there are days where, not even because something bad's happened in your life, there are days where you just... You know, I think there are days where I find it much harder. And the common denominator is, and I think what people don't always realize about, you know, people in our position is,
你能不能为他们女儿的 16 岁生日录一小段视频的人。当然了，也有一些日子——甚至都不是因为你生活里发生了什么坏事——有些日子你就是……你知道的，我觉得有些日子我应付起来困难得多。共同点在于，我觉得人们并不总是意识到，（你知道的）处于我们这个位置的人，
normally the days where you feel less good about being available to the public are days where you feel less good about being available to the public are days where you feel terrible about yourself. You know, they're the days where your relationship to self is so weak, whether it's because, I listened to one of your episodes the other day, Sean, you know, you said that you'd eaten,
通常那些你觉得不太乐意面对公众的日子，通常那些你觉得不太乐意面对公众的日子，往往也是你觉得自己状态糟糕透顶的日子。你知道的，那些日子里，你与自我的关系是如此脆弱，不管是因为什么——我前几天听了你们的一期节目，Sean，（你知道的）你说你在晚上 11 点吃了一些
I don't know, some mac and cheese at 11 p.m. at night. You know, when I listen to that. You're going to have to narrow down the episode. But the guy who wakes up the next day is not going to be as good at being the guy to take selfies as the guy who's just done 10 weeks eating chicken, broccoli and rice and is kind of ready to go. That's my experience of the world anyway. So in answer to your question, Jason, I find it at times, I love it.
通心粉加奶酪。你知道的，当我听到那个……你得把具体是哪一集缩小范围。但第二天醒来的那家伙，肯定不如刚坚持了 10 周只吃鸡肉、西兰花和米饭、随时准备开工的那个家伙那么擅长应付自拍。反正这就是我的亲身经历。所以回答你的问题，Jason，我有的时候会很喜欢。
If I feel psychologically, emotionally robust enough to be available for people, I'm great at it. But it chops and changes. Where did you have to be, and you probably still, it's an ongoing thing, are you helpful to your family and your friends, like where you are right now? You can't just like slide into Wales,
如果我感觉自己在心理上、情绪上足够强大，能够为别人抽出时间，我很擅长应付。但这种状态总是变来变去的。你当时必须身处何地——可能现在也是如此，这是一个持续的过程——你对家人和朋友有帮助吗，比如你现在的处境？你不能就这样轻描淡写地回到威尔士，
fresh off the set down in Australia, and expect everyone to be as kind of easy with the light switch as you are. Like, do you have to help them kind of intellectualise what's happened to their dear Taron as well, right? Like, now you're known all over the world, and you've got all this money and all this access, and so, I mean, there's a bit of a responsibility on your end to make them comfortable with it too, question?
刚拍完澳大利亚的片子杀青，就指望每个人都能像你一样轻松地切换状态。比如，你是不是得帮他们理清究竟发生了什么，好让他们接受他们亲爱的 Taron 的改变，对吧？因为现在全世界都知道你了，你有了这么多钱和这么大的影响力，所以，我是说，你得承担一部分责任，让他们也能坦然接受这一切，这是个问题吗？
Well, I think I'm lucky. I'm from a well-adjusted, you know, my family are well-adjusted and cool and I think we're very empathetic and understanding. So they really see, I feel very seen very clearly by my family and by the people who are important to me in my life. And I guess I feel like, I don't know, sorry, I got distracted because I don't know if that was my... It was like a getaway car. It was like some sort of souped up engine.
嗯，我觉得我很幸运。我来自一个很和谐的家庭，你知道的，我的家人们都非常融洽、很酷，而且我觉得我们都很有同理心和理解力。所以他们真的很懂我，我觉得在我的家人和我生命中重要的人眼里，我是被非常清楚地看到的。我想我感觉，我不知道，抱歉，我分心了，因为我不知道那是不是我的……那就像是一辆逃亡的车。那就像某种改装过发动机的车。
And you know, to that point, Jason, it's easy of lament the drawbacks of being famous or noteworthy, but it's awesome to be You've quite literally, and I'm sure members of my family are listening, sisters and or mom or whatever, and where I've had moments where I've said, hey, I'm really sorry that I put you in this position. I didn't do it on purpose, but you find yourself almost apologizing. Well, sure, because everyone's involved. I mean, you know, Willie, you walk down the street
而且你知道，就这一点而言，杰森，人们很容易去哀叹成名或引人注目的弊端，但成名真的很棒。你确实——字面意义上的，而且我确信我的家人们在听，姐姐们和/或妈妈或者什么的，在某些时刻我会说，嘿，真的很抱歉我把你置于这种境地。我不是故意的，但你会发现自己几乎在道歉。嗯，当然，因为每个人都牵涉其中。我的意思是，你知道的，威利，当你带着孩子走在街上
with your kids and a photographer gets up in your face, you kind of know how to flow with it, but maybe your kids aren't even thinking about the fact that their dad is famous and that's like weird. Can I tell you something funny that Abel, my 14 year old is a really funny kid, said the other day, we were talking about another friend of all of ours who's very well known globally
而一个摄影师把相机凑到你脸上时，你多少知道该怎么顺其自然，但也许你的孩子们根本没想过他们的爸爸是个名人，而这感觉挺怪的。我能告诉你一件有趣的事吗？我的大儿子阿贝尔今年14岁，是个挺搞笑的孩子，前几天他说，我们在聊起另一个我们大家都认识的、在全球范围内非常知名的人时
and he was talking about them and he said, ah man, thank God we're not that famous. And what I found was- And we'll start drinking again. and he was talking about them and he said, Oh man, thank God we're not that famous. What I found really funny about it was A, his sort of perception of where everything was on a scale, and B, the weir of it all. It's a circus group. I love that.
他在谈论他们时说，天哪，谢天谢地我们没那么有名。我觉得真正有趣的是——我们又要开始喝酒了。而他在谈论他们时说，噢天哪，谢天谢地我们没那么有名。我觉得这整件事最搞笑的地方在于，第一，他对各项事物在尺度上所处位置的某种感知；第二，这整件事的诡异之处。这简直就是个马戏团。我太喜欢这个了。
Wait, so Will Beggs, go ahead. No, I was going to ask. I'm excited to hear, I'm excited for your project with the one that's based on the conversation with John Bishop. Yes. Is this thing on, right? Yeah.
等等，威利·贝格斯，你接着说。不，我正要问。我很高兴听到，我很期待你和约翰·比什铺那次谈话改编的项目。是的。这东西开着呢，对吧？对。
That's so, when I heard about that, it was such a collision. You're familiar with him, yeah, Taron? I know, well I know him. I've said hello to him a few times in passing at various things. Great guy. It was such a collision. I've said hello to him a few times in passing at various things. My family are from Liverpool. Anyone from that part of the world I kind of feel a vague affinity with. Congrats on the championship. Let's get it out of the way.
太——当我听说这件事时，那真是一次奇妙的交集。你熟悉他，对吧，塔伦？我知道，呃，我认识他。我在各种场合擦肩而过时跟他打过几次招呼。他人超好。那真是一次奇妙的交集。我在各种场合擦肩而过时跟他打过几次招呼。我的家人来自利物浦。对于来自世界那个角落的任何人，我都会有一种莫名的亲切感。祝贺你们赢得冠军。我们先把它略过吧。
Obviously a terrible thing happened. Let's get it out of the way. Yeah, it's obviously a terrible thing happened. Some people were injured when a guy drove into the celebration. John's an amazing guy, proper scouser, just a really cool dude. Got to know him a little bit and then through that, sort of, you know, inspired this film. They're talking about the main figure that is the inspiration for Will's upcoming film with Bradley Cooper. That's right, yes.
显然发生了一件糟糕的事。我们先把它略过吧。对，显然发生了一件糟糕的事。当一个人开车冲进庆祝人群时，有一些人受伤了。约翰是个极好的人，地道的利物浦人，就是一个真的很酷的家伙。我稍微了解了他一点，然后通过这个，算是，你知道的，激发了这部电影的灵感。他们正在谈论作为威利即将与布莱德利·库珀合作的新电影灵感来源的那个人物。没，是的。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. We just finished, yeah. So yeah, it was a lot of fun, and he's such a great guy and his life is fascinating. Did you write this? Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's cool. With Mark Chappell, who's a friend of the podcast, Chapp Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's cool.
对，对，对，对。我们刚刚拍完，对。所以，对，这非常有趣，而且他真的是个很棒的人，他的人生超级迷人。这是你写的吗？对。对，对，对。太酷了。和马克·查佩尔一起，他是本播客的好朋友，查皮。对。对，对，对。太酷了。
With Mark Chappell, who's a friend of the podcast, Chappie. Dang, we got it. Magic word of the day. And Bradley, of course, too. So the three of us, yeah, yeah, yeah. So had you not gotten into the Royal Academy, was there, were you sort of getting ready to maybe do something else? Because that was right at the age when you kind of getting ready to maybe do
和马克·查佩尔一起，他是本播客的好朋友，查皮。天哪，我们说出来了。今日魔幻词。还有布莱德利，当然还有他。所以我们三个，对，对，对。那么，如果你当初没有进入皇家戏剧艺术学院，是不是有什么——你当时是不是正准备去做点别的？因为那正好是你那种时候——你差不多得准备去做
something else? Because that was right at the age when you kind of had to decide, right? Oh man, like that's a conversation that happens regularly in my family, you know. We have a lot of pinch me and dreamy moments while I've been away filming at the house. I mean now we've been renovating for a long period of time
点别的？因为那正好是你那种时候——你差不多得决定了，对吧？噢天哪，这确实是我家里经常聊起的一个话题，你知道的。当我在屋外拍戏时，我们有过很多“掐掐自己看是不是在做梦”的梦幻时刻。我的意思是，现在我们已经装修了很长一段时间
and it's kind of just coming to fruition, it's just coming together and you know, it's been made possible largely through what's happened to me in my life and we did have that conversation over dinner the other day, you know, what the fuck would you have done if you hadn't been an actor? Because I can't do anything else.
而它现在总算有点成果了，一切都在慢慢成形，你知道的，这在很大程度上要归功于我生活中发生的这些改变。我们前几天在吃晚饭时确实聊过这个话题，你知道的，如果你当时没有当演员，你特么能干什么？因为我什么也干不了。
I can't do anything else. Getting ready for this podcast was so stressful because it involved me opening a MacBook and changing the settings, plugging a mic into the device. These things are totally beyond my abilities. I'm the world's weakest millennial. Well first of all, it should be noted, Taron, we've done over 250 episodes.
我什么也干不了。为这个播客做准备压力太大了，因为它需要我打开MacBook并更改设置，把麦克风插到设备上。这些事情完全超出了我的能力范围。我是全世界最废物的千禧一代。嗯，首先，得说明一下，塔伦，我们已经录了250多期节目了。
I don't know if you watched Sean this morning trying to do it. He couldn't connect. Over 250. Imagine if he was our pilot. I can't connect thoughts. Let alone a computer. So then, Taron, it would be safe to say you probably would have been more on the labor side of things? Well, I don't know.
我不知道你今天早上有没有看肖恩试图搞定这些。他根本连不上。250多期。想象一下如果他是我们的飞行员。我连思绪都连不上。更别说电脑了。所以，塔伦，这么说来，你大概会更倾向于体力劳动那一挂的？嗯，我不知道。
Honestly, I really don't know. You mean pushing a wheelbarrow? Is that what you're saying? Or swinging a hammer, you know, whatever it is. Yeah, maybe... Wow, yeah, swinging a hammer. There's people who'd laugh at the prospect of me swinging a hammer. I can't put up a set of shelves. I don't know. I think... I'm not great at it myself.
老实说，我真的不知道。你是说推独轮车？你是这意思吗？还是挥锤子，你知道的，随便什么。对，也许……哇，对，挥锤子。有些人听到我要挥锤子估计会笑掉大牙。我都不会装一套书架。我不知道。我觉得……我自己其实也不太擅长。
I think I'd have figured something out, but it's true that acting is the only thing that I ever felt a huge, kind of cosmic pull towards. And I love it. I absolutely love it. Could have been singing. Now, I did not know this. You, correct me if I'm wrong, because I'm just, you know, Wikipedia is my research partner. You sang with Sir Elton John, recorded the song that won an Academy Award for best original song. That's right, yeah. I mean, huh?
我想我总能想出点办法，但确实，演戏是我这辈子唯一一个让我感受到巨大的、某种宇宙般吸引力的东西。我爱它。我绝对爱它。也可能是唱歌。现在，我可不知道这个。你——如果我错了请纠正我，因为我只是，你知道的，维基百科是我的研究伙伴。你曾和埃尔顿·约翰爵士一起唱歌，录制了那首赢得奥斯卡最佳原创歌曲奖的歌。没错，对。我是说，啊？
Wait, what? So did you sing with him on that song? Yeah, so he wrote... It's in the movie Rocketman. I love the movie. Thanks, Sean. I think it's the credit song and it's a song that he and Bernie wrote for the movie that we sing as a duet. I think it's like a call and response sort of deal, you know? And yeah, they won an Oscar for it. They you?
等等，什么？所以你跟他在那首歌里合唱了吗？对，所以他写了……它在电影《火箭人》里。我超喜欢这部电影。谢谢你，肖恩。我想那是片尾曲，这是他和伯尼为电影写的一首歌，我们俩作为对唱来唱。我觉得这有点像那种一问一答的形式，你知道吗？然后，是的，他们因此赢得了一个奥斯卡奖。你吗？
You sang it? It's a duet? Do you get to do it? and then later they recorded his part. No, we went in and sang together in the studio. Wow. It was a lovely experience. Pretty wild. Of course by this time you guys were probably close buddies
你唱的？这是一首对唱？轮到你唱吗？然后他们后来才录了他的部分。不，我们一起走进录音室合唱的。哇。那是一次非常美好的体验。挺疯狂的。当然，到这个时候你们俩可能已经是好哥们了
because was he a part of your early research, auditioning, et cetera, et cetera? Yeah, so I sang, the animated movie that you mentioned when you intro'd me is called Sing and I sang I'm Still Standing in that movie. And then in the Kingsman sequel, Elton came along and played himself. And through those two things, the conversation around me playing him in Rocketman came about
因为他是否参与了你早期的调研、试镜等等等等？对，所以我唱了——你介绍我时提到的那部动画电影叫《欢乐好声音》，我在那部电影里唱了《I'm Still Standing》。然后在那部《王牌特工》的续集里，埃尔顿客串并饰演了他自己。通过这两件事，关于由我在《火箭人》里饰演他的讨论就产生了
and grew from there. So, wait, wait. In turn, did the two of you kind of have that conversation on the set and you guys decided well maybe we should go out and kind of pitch this together? Matthew Vaughan, who directed the Kingsman films and has produced a couple of other things that I've been in as well. and we were there to kind of step in basically. That's cool. Attaboy.
并由此发展开来。所以，等等，等等。反过来，你们俩当时在片场是不是就顺势聊过这个，然后你们决定，也许我们应该出去把这个项目一起推销出去？马修·沃恩，他执导了《王牌特工》系列，还制作了我参演过的另外几部作品。而我们在那儿基本上就是为了顺水推舟。太酷了。干得好，小伙子。
Wow. Nothing even opportunistic. Yeah. I love that. Well listen, I mean it's the right place, right time. That's a famous part of our business. And the movie, when I saw the movie, you were so great in it, I love that movie.
哇。一点也不带投机取巧的色彩。对。我太喜欢这个了。好吧，听着，我的意思是，这就是天时地利。这是我们这行里很出名的一点。那部电影，当我看到那部电影时，你在里面演得太棒了，我超喜欢那部电影。
I have notes. Are you guys picture locked? Because I did. No, but when I was watching it, I was like, oh you sure you're not Sherlocked? Because I did. No, but when I was watching, I was like, oh well the next logical move is to make the movie a stage musical. Yes, I've thought the same thing. Right, I mean it's like done, it's all done.
我有意见要提。你们画面剪辑定稿了吗？因为我当时——没有，但我在看的时候，我在想，噢，你确定你不是“神探夏洛克”吗？因为我当时——没有，但我在看的时候，我在想，噢，那接下来顺理成章的一步就是把这部电影改成舞台音乐剧。是的，我也这么想过。对，我的意思是，这就像是完成了，全盘搞定了。
And so I just didn't know if you wanted to ever, if you were part of that conversation or whatever. No, no, I'm sure it's occurred to them. David and Elton, they obviously, I know that they've got various irons in the fire with theatrical endeavors, and I'm sure it's occurred to them. You're friends with Elton, right?
所以我只是不知道你是否曾经想过——你是否参与过那种讨论，或者诸如此类的。不，不，我确信他们肯定想过。大卫和埃尔顿，他们显然——我知道他们在戏剧事业上有各种各样的计划在推进，我确信他们肯定想过。你是埃尔顿的朋友，对吧？
Yeah, yeah, we've hung out for a month. I don't know whether they've ever considered it seriously, but I don't think it would involve me. It's one of those things that I'm so, it was such a moment in my life, and something I'm so fiercely proud of that I just wouldn't want to touch it. For sure, you already did it.
对，对，我们一起厮混了一个月。我不知道他们是否曾认真考虑过，但我觉得这应该不会带上我。这是那种让我感慨万千的事，它是我生命中的一个高光时刻，也是一件让我无比自豪的事情，以至于我根本不想去触碰它。肯定的，你已经演过啦。
Yeah. You already did it. We'll be right back. And back to the show. Well, a completely different experience with the success of a project than what you experienced on your other projects that have been equally successful. I mean, I would imagine that the Kingsman process
对。你已经演过啦。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。嗯，一个项目的成功所带来的完全不同的体验，和你之前同样成功的其他项目相比——我的意思是，我能想象《王牌特工》的整个过程
was probably more startling and challenging to you because it was the first big splash into public view. more startling and challenging to you I'm sure we could do agent, and at the time it was called Huntsman and Son, and it didn't have the script, but it had two scenes in it. And one of the scenes was the scene where I first meet Colin Firth's character in the pub. And I didn't know Colin was involved, I didn't know Michael Caine was involved, I didn't know anyone was involved.
对你来说可能更加惊艳且具有挑战性，因为那是你第一次大张旗鼓地进入公众视野。更加惊艳且具有挑战性。我确信我们可以找个经纪人，当时它叫《猎人与子嗣》，而且还没有剧本，但里面有两场戏。其中一场戏就是我第一次在酒吧里遇到科林·费斯角色的那场戏。我当时不知道科林参与了，我不知道迈克尔·凯恩参与了，我不知道任何人参与了。
But I read the scene, and I don't know about you guys, but I don't know about you guys, but I find that whenever I'm excited about a piece of writing, I start reading it aloud, And I don't know about you guys, but I find that whenever I'm excited about a piece of writing, I start reading it aloud. I know the street corner I was on in London, and I was reading this scene, and I started reading it aloud. Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, I've got to get that part. That's my part. And I've never actually had it since. I've never had that level of certainty.
但我读了那场戏，我不知道你们怎么样，但我不知道你们怎么样，我发现每当我看到一段让我兴奋的剧本时，我就会开始大声朗读它，而且我不知道你们怎么样，我发现每当我看到一段让我兴奋的剧本时，我就会开始大声朗读它。我知道我当时在伦敦的哪个街角，我正在读这场戏，然后我开始大声朗读它。我必须拿到那个角色。那是我的角色。而且我之后再也没有过那种感觉了。我再也没有过那种百分之百的笃定感。
They say nowadays you manifested it. Yeah, well, it felt like that. These hippie-dippie kids today. No, come on, man. You've got to put it out. I tell you a film of yours, Taron, that I really love. I loved all your films and you're going to carry on. Sorry. I catch you off. I never saw that one.
他们现在说这就叫“吸引力法则”。对，好吧，感觉确实如此。现在这些嬉皮士小年轻啊。不，拜托，老兄。你得把它释放出来。我跟你说一部你的电影，塔伦，我真的很喜欢。我喜欢你所有的电影，而且你会继续——抱歉。我打断你了。我从没看过那部。
Is that the one where your character wore a ball cap? What a choice. Did you guys see what he's doing? No, we're not going to cut that. We're going to loop it. Did you guys see Taron in Tetris? I loved that movie, man. I didn't see it. I want to see it. It's such a great, cool film about how that game came about. I love that game.
那是你的角色戴着棒球帽的那部吗？真是个绝佳的选择。你们看到他在干什么了吗？不，我们不把这剪掉。我们要把它循环播放。你们看到塔伦演的《俄罗斯方块》了吗？我太喜欢那部电影了，老兄。我没看过。我很想看。那是一部非常棒、非常酷的电影，讲的是那个游戏是怎么诞生的。我太喜欢那个游戏了。
It's a fascinating story, isn't it? It's a really fascinating story. Yeah, it was cool. I think you're one of about 27 people who saw it. So I'm really thrilled. It's a great little movie, man. It's about the guys that designed that game? Yeah, it was cool. who designed the game in Russia before the war in 89. So yeah, it's a fun movie that was released on Apple. It's amazing and people are trying to sort of muscle their way in to grab the license for it because they understand the impact that it's going to have.
这是一个迷人的故事，不是吗？这真的是一个迷人的故事。对，很酷。我想你是大约27个看过它的人之一。所以我真的太激动了。这是一部很棒的小成本电影，老兄。讲的是设计那个游戏的人吗？对，很酷。在89年战争爆发前在俄罗斯设计了这款游戏的人。所以，是的，这是一部在苹果上线的有趣电影。它太棒了，人们正试图挤破头去抢它的版权，因为他们明白它将产生的影响。
It's a fascinating film. Well I do like the game. So I'll watch the movie Is that you do have such a crush on candy It's so true, but wait go back to the America thing for just a second, Taren. Okay. No, like, cause I want to know, like, so I got your impression that, you know, cause I'm always fascinated with the perspective of people in other countries that come here and work here.
这是一部迷人的电影。嗯，我确实很喜欢这个游戏。所以我一定会去看这部电影的。你对糖果也太着迷了吧？确实如此，不过等等，塔伦，我们稍微回到美国这个话题上。好的。不，比如说，因为我想知道，所以我的印象是，你知道的，因为我总是对其他国家的人来到这里并在这里工作时的视角着迷。
What was it like when you first worked here? And was it everything that you thought it would be or what was not? It was better. I love America. I bought a home in America. You feel comfortable here? I absolutely do.
当你第一次在这里工作时，那是什么体验？它是否符合你所有的设想，或者有哪些地方不是？比想象的还要好。我爱美国。我在美国买了个房子。你在这里感觉自在吗？我绝对觉得自在。
And whenever I have meetings with prospective directors or writers, quite often people ask, what is the perception of America now, given everything that's happening? Yeah, we'd like to know that. Please go ahead. And I don't know, I think it depends on who you are, but my experience of America, regardless of where you go,
每当我与潜在的导演或编剧开会时，人们经常会问：鉴于目前发生的一切，现在对美国的看法是怎样的？对，我们也想知道这个。请继续吧。我不知道，我想这取决于你是谁，但我对美国的体验，无论你去哪里
and I've visited various places, not just New York and LA, but the people in America, from my experience, generally, it's just a wonderful place. I remember when I first landed in New York, I had a really weird feeling that I was like, I don't know if it's because I've watched Home Alone too many times, but it felt like coming home, you know?
而且我去过各种各样的地方，不仅仅是纽约和洛杉矶，根据我的经验，美国的人们，总的来说，这里就是一个美妙的地方。我记得我第一次在纽约降落时，有一种非常奇妙的感觉，我在想，我不知道是不是因为我看《小鬼当家》看太多次了，但那种感觉就像是回到了家，你知道吗？
There's a warmth and an ink. I think historically, there is an inclusiveness at the heart of what America is, it seems to me, that I really love about it. Yeah, a melting pot. Yeah, melting pot. Yeah, and I have nothing.
有一种温暖和包容。我认为从历史上看，在美国的核心里存在着一种包容性，在我看来，这也是我非常喜欢它的一点。对，大熔炉。对，大熔炉。对，而且我毫无——
I mean, as I say, I have a house in California that I, you know, split my time between. That's great. Yeah, I love being in the States. Why, what's your fear, Sean? No, no, I like to know different people's perception because I find it fascinating. I mean, when I go over to London, or people ask the same thing, what do you think of London,
我的意思是，就像我说的，我在加州有一栋房子，你知道的，我有一部分时间在那边度过。那太棒了。对，我很喜欢待在美国。怎么了，你在担心什么，肖恩？不，不，我只是想了解不同的人对这里的看法，因为我觉得这很迷人。我的意思是，当我去伦敦时，或者人们也会问同样的问题，你觉得伦敦怎么样
what do you think of England, whatever, and I absolutely love it over there. I mean, I haven't been to Wales, but I need to go to Wales. Yeah, I'd like to go to Wales. Yeah, and I mean, it strikes me that, you have such microcosmic identities when you move from one place to another in a country.
你觉得英格兰怎么样，诸如此类的，而我真的超级喜欢那边。我的意思是，我没去过威尔士，但我需要去一趟威尔士。对，我也想去一趟威尔士。对，而且我的感觉是，当你从一个地方搬到一个国家的另一个地方时，你们拥有如此微观各异的身份认同。
If you spent a weekend in Liverpool, it's going to be vastly different from your experience in Edinburgh or whatever. Right, and I walk around London last time I was there just a couple months ago, and I'm like, everywhere you go, it's incredible history, which we don't have here. And I talk to people about it,
如果你在利物浦度过一个周末，那将与你在爱丁堡或其他地方的体验大不相同。没错，我上次去伦敦的时候就在那里四处转悠，那还是几个月前，我想，你无论走到哪里，都有着令人难以置信的历史，而这是我们这里所没有的。我跟人们聊起这个
and this one girl I know over there, she's like, yeah, I always forget to look up. I'm like, what do you mean? She's like, I always look, I always forget to look up and look at these historical buildings because everybody's just so used to it. So fresh eyes is really cool.
我认识的那边的一个女孩，她说，对啊，我总是忘记抬头看。我说，你什么意思？她说，我总是看——我总是忘记抬头看看这些历史建筑，因为每个人都对它们习以为常了。所以用全新的视角去看真的很酷。
That's what I've always asked people who aren't from here, what do your fresh eyes see? Yeah. Now, Taron, you know, you are managing to knock off really great commercial projects, really good sort of like artistic projects. Like, is this just dumb luck? No.
这就是我一直问那些不是本地人的人的问题：你们全新的视角看到了什么？对。话说回来，塔伦，你知道的，你既能拍出非常棒的商业项目，又能拍出非常不错的艺术类项目。像这种成就是单纯的瞎猫碰上死耗子吗？不是。
You're doing some sort of really good deliberate work in choosing what you do. What does the perfect project kind of look like to you? Is it about the part? really good, deliberate work in choosing what you do. What does the perfect project kind of look like to you? Is it about the part? Is it about the people involved? Is it theater versus streaming versus theatrical? What do you look for? I don't know. You operate within the constraints of what you're asked to do.
你在选择做什么项目时做了一些非常棒的、深思熟虑的工作。对你来说，完美的项目长什么样？是关于角色的吗？非常棒的、深思熟虑的工作。对你来说，完美的项目长什么样？是关于角色的吗？是关于参与的人的吗？是戏剧对流媒体对大银幕电影吗？你在寻找什么？我不知道。你只能在别人对你的要求所带来的局限性内行事。
And the grass is always greener. You cooperate within the constraints of what you're asked to do and the grass is always greener. I could let a side of myself out where I would lament not doing certain things and there are things that I would love to be doing, but you have to focus on the things that are available to you. I'm so lucky. And I do get offered things that feel... I know that I try and look for things that feel different from a character perspective. So I'm not comfortable. I don't like the idea of being... Pigeonholed.
而且“邻家的草总是更绿”。你只能在别人对你的要求所带来的局限性内行事，而且“邻家的草总是更绿”。我有时也会释放出自己的一面，去哀叹自己没有做某些事情，而且确实有些事是我很想去做的，但你必须专注于那些对你来说触手可及的事情。我太幸运了。而且我确实会接到一些感觉——我知道我试着去寻找那些从角色角度来看能带来不同感觉的东西。所以我不会让自己感到舒适。我不喜欢这种感觉，就是被……类型化。
Yeah, put in a box or whatever. I mean, in fact, you know, when we did Carry On, my biggest concern about... What a picture! Oh, the man out of the airplay to play Apple in a lamp-peeler! Bravo! The only thing that happened when they rolled credits is I wish they would carry on this picture. Yes, sure.
对，被限制在某种框框里之类。事实上，你知道的，当我们拍《凭栏一击》时，我最大的担忧在于——多棒的一部电影啊！哦，那个从飞机里走出来演了一个绝佳角色的家伙！太棒了！片尾字幕滚完后唯一美中不足的就是我真希望他们能接着拍这部电影。没错，当然。
Oh, no, no, no! Where is the sequel? Sorry, we'll get him out soon. He's running around the balcony. Go ahead. Yeah, I was... I worried that it was too... Good. Too vanilla or whatever. It was too vanilla or whatever.
噢，不，不，不！续集在哪里？抱歉，我们很快把他带回来。他在阳台上乱跑呢。你继续。对，我当时——我担心它太……好了。太流于俗套了之类的。它太流于俗套了之类的。
It was too near to me. It was a kind of average Joe guy. And I suppose the actors that I look up to and really admire and revere are the actors who try and stretch themselves and be... Like with a ball cap. Right, do I have a limb? Lymph and a missing tooth and a weird accent.
它太贴近我本色了。那是一种普通人的感觉。我想我所敬仰、真正钦佩和崇拜的演员，是那些试图突破自我、去挑战……像戴着棒球帽的那种。没错，身上带点残疾？
Oh, wow, I heard that. But I try and look at things like, you know, I'm missing tooth and a weird accent. But I try and look at things like, after Elton, I went and did the show for Dennis Lehane, Blackbird, which I felt satisfying because it's a... I definitely like doing things that feel different. I suppose I aspire to be, you know, like a... I like character actors. I like actors who are different from one thing to the next. Character actor, yeah.
噢，哇，我听到那个了。但我试着去看一些像——你知道的，带个缺牙和奇怪口音的角色。但我试着去看一些像这样的事：演完埃尔顿之后，我去拍了丹尼斯·勒hane的剧《黑鸟》，我觉得那很令人满足，因为那是一个——我绝对喜欢做那些感觉不同的事。我想我的志向是，你知道的，成为一个——我喜欢性格演员。我喜欢那些从一个角色到下一个角色判若两人的演员。性格演员，对。
And unfortunately, you're too goddamn good looking to be a true character actor, so you have to act your way into that perception, and you're doing it, and you're getting opportunities now with scripts that lend itself to that. And so, you're doing it and you're getting opportunities now with scripts that lend itself to that. And so, you know, it's. I'm going to ask you the Jason Baby question,
但不幸的是，你长得特么太帅了，当不成一个真正的性格演员，所以你必须通过演技来扭转这种刻板印象，而你正在这么做，你现在正获得与这种形象契合的剧本机会。所以，你知道的，这是——我要问你杰森的那个经典问题，
which is you've been doing it now for a while and you've done a lot of great work. Do you see yourself doing different stuff as in directing or writing something? That's a great question. It's kind of where I'm from. No, I mean, you know, I feel, I listened to you guys talking with Jude Law and he summed it up pretty good.
那就是你现在已经干这行一段时间了，而且你拍了很多优秀的作品。你觉得自己未来会尝试不同的事情，比如导演或者写剧本吗？这真是个好问题。这有点像我的出身。不，我的意思是，你知道的，我觉得——我听了你们跟裘德·洛的对话，他总结得相当精辟。
This is another great one of the Optima greats. We have got to get a caller on that guy. He's disrupting the record. Go ahead. Please go ahead. But I feel that way. It scares me, you know, and I have such admiration for anyone who makes that leap because I'd love, I'd absolutely love to do it.
这也是奥普提马（Optima）伟人中的又一个。我们得给那家伙打个电话。他把整个记录都打破了。你接着说。请继续说。但我也那种感觉。这让我感到害怕，你知道的，我对任何迈出那一步的人都充满了敬佩，因为我很想——我绝对很想去尝试。
Of course I would, but I... What's going on with Smoke? What's going on? This is the Apple show that's coming out June 27th. Yes. What drew you to it? What is it about? Is this gonna be different than the thing
我当然想，但我……《烟雾迷城》是怎么回事？怎么回事？这是Apple将于6月27日播出的剧集。是的。是什么吸引了你？它讲的是什么？这会和那部
that immediately precedes it, like as you're just talking about doing? Yeah, I think so. I think it's definitely different from anything I've done before. So it's created by Dennis Lahane, who was the creator, showrunner of Blackbird. And when we finished shooting that show, he approached me about doing another story. And it's one of those, the trailer's out, it's just come out, but it's one of those
紧挨着它之前播出的作品有什么不同吗？就像你刚才说的那种尝试？是的，我想是的。我想它绝对和我以往演过的任何角色都不一样。所以它是丹尼斯·勒翰创作的，他也是《黑鸟》的创作者和制片人。当我们拍完那部剧后，他找我聊了另一个故事。这是一部那种——预告片已经发布了，刚刚出来，但它属于那种
is really hard to describe. But the user-friendly log line is I play an arson investigator who is having very, very limited success catching two prolific arsonists in a fictional town called Umberland. And a police detective is brought in to help him solve these arsons basically. And that role's played by Journey Smollett. And what you learn over the course of the show is that he is harboring some secrets.
真的很很难描述的作品。但通俗易懂的梗概是：我饰演一名纵火案调查员，在一个名为乌姆兰的虚构小镇上，在抓捕两名高产的系列纵火犯时，取得的进展非常非常有限。然后找来了一名女警探来帮他侦破这些纵火案。这个角色由朱莉·斯莫利特饰演。随着剧情的发展，你会发现他怀揣着一些秘密。
And it's one of those shows where I don't really know... This is the first bit of press I'm doing for it, and I have no idea how to promote it without kind of giving it away. But is there enough in there to craft some sort of logon? Yeah, yeah. But basically, for anyone who's seen Blackbird, it's a kind of sister piece, I suppose. Well, Dennis Lehane, I mean, it's this guy, tip-top.
这是一部那种我真的不知道……这是我为它做的第一场宣传活动，我完全不知道该怎么在不剧透的情况下宣传它。但里面有足够的信息来凑个剧情梗概吗？对，对。但基本上，对于任何看过《黑鸟》的人来说，它算是一部姊妹篇吧。好吧，丹尼斯·勒翰，我的意思是，这家伙，绝对顶尖。
Now, Taron, you're drunk, you're out at a karaoke bar, you're feeling good. What's your go-to karaoke song? Yeah. Faith, George Michael. Oh yeah, you got to have Faith what's your go-to karaoke song? Faith, George Michael. Oh yeah, you got it right. I bet that's good. Faith, George Michael is a good one.
好了，塔伦，如果你喝醉了，去了卡拉OK酒吧，感觉正嗨。你必点的卡拉OK曲目是什么？对。乔治·迈克的《Faith》。噢，对，你必须得唱《Faith》。你必点的卡拉OK曲目是什么？乔治·迈克的《Faith》。噢，对，你答对了。我敢打赌这首歌肯定不错。乔治·迈克的《Faith》是个不错的选择。
Didn't take you a long time to answer that. How many times have you performed that? That's a long-standing one. And it depends on the mood as well. If it's like a kind of, I don't know, if I'm looking for a bit more gravitas, maybe a couple of radio head numbers, like Bones, or Sulk, or, you know, really dirty, maybe like Blackstar,
你没花多长时间就回答出来了。你唱过这首歌多少次了？这是一首老牌保留曲目了。这还得看心情。如果是一种——我不知道，如果我在寻找更多厚重感的话，可能会选几首电台司令（Radiohead）的歌，比如《Bones》或者《Sulk》，或者，你知道的，真的很暗黑的歌，比如《Blackstar》，
something like that. Yeah. Well, you're off the first album. What's yours, Jason? I love that you have a few available. Jason, never would do it. Yeah, mine's just, I'm just on the Uber app looking for a ride out of there.
诸如此类的。对。嗯，你挑的都是第一张专辑里的。你呢，杰森？我太喜欢你居然还有好几首备选了。杰森绝对不会去唱。对，我的话就是——我正打开优步APP叫车离开那儿呢。
Oh, I'm... Mine's the theme to The Greatest American Hero. Is that true? Okay. Yeah, remember that? Believe it or not, I'm walking on air. Remember that song? Da da da da da da da.
噢，我……我的是《最伟大的美国英雄》的主题曲。真的吗？好吧。对，还记得那首歌吗？信不信由你，我腾云驾雾。还记得那歌吗？达达哒哒哒哒哒。
Mine is, no joke, mine is Crazy by Patsy Cline, always. Really? Crazy. Yeah. What do you mean, always? Crazy. How much time are you doing in a karaoke? I'm doing a lot of karaoke, man. Once a week?
说真的，我必点的是帕齐·克莱真的《Crazy》，每次都点。真的吗？《Crazy》。对。什么叫“每次都点”？《Crazy》。你到底花多少时间在卡拉OK上啊？我经常去卡拉OK，老兄。一周一次？
You don't know my life. I don't know. Do you sing, Jason? Do you week? You don't know my life. I don't know. Do you sing, Jason? I don't, not even in the shower. Next question. Which is why I want to hear you sing so bad. I have to start drinking again. There's so little joy in your spirit.
你又不了解我的生活。我不知道。你会唱歌吗，杰森？一周一次？你又不了解我的生活。我不知道。你会唱歌吗，杰森？我不会，连在淋浴时都不会。下一个问题。这就是为什么我那么想听你唱歌。我得重新开始喝酒了。你的灵魂里简直毫无乐趣可言。
Literally the last time I sang was in a karaoke bar, doing press for Horrible Bosses 2, and I think I was still drinking, wasn't I? Maybe? I don't know. No, you weren't. No way, right? And you did karaoke?
我字面意义上最后一次唱歌是在一家卡拉OK酒吧，当时是在为《恶老板2》做宣传，我觉得我当时还在喝酒，对吧？也许吧？我不知道。不，你当时没喝。不可能吧，对吧？然后你还去唱了卡拉OK？
I did, and fucking Sudeikis, this guy, you know, this guy's a natural performer. He's a talent, he can sing and dance. I'd love to see a smackdown between you and Sudeikis. Yeah, I think Taron would take him down, though. But that would be a real, that'd be a heavyweight fight. Has he got a voice? He sings? He's got a voice and he's also just got like,
我唱了，然后特么的苏戴奇斯这个家伙——你知道的，这家伙是个天生的表演者。他是个天才，又会唱歌又会跳舞。我很想看你和苏戴奇斯来一场对决。对，不过我觉得塔伦能把他打趴下。但那绝对会是一场重量级的比赛。他有嗓音吗？他会唱歌吗？他有嗓音，而且他属于那种
the guy's not uncomfortable with the microphone in his hand. Yeah, he's great. That's a certain talent. Yeah, I sort of find it easier when there's a character I can hide behind. So the show, they wrote in a whole bit in this new show I have coming out called Smoke, a character I can hide behind. They wrote in a whole bit in this new show I have coming out called Smoke, where my guy is obsessed with karaoke. I noticed that I find it much easier to do it on set as a character
手里拿着麦克风完全不会觉得尴尬的家伙。对，他很厉害。那也是一种天赋。对，我有时觉得，如果有个能让我藏身的角色，事情就会变得容易得多。所以这部新剧——他们在我即将上映的新剧《烟雾迷城》里专门写了一整段剧情，一个能让我藏身的角色。他们在我即将上映的新剧《烟雾迷城》里专门写了一整段剧情，里面我饰演的这家伙是个卡拉OK狂热爱好者。我发现，作为角色在片场做这件事，要比在我的现实生活中
than if I do it in my own personal life. Life at a pub or something. I find it quite stressful. No, we're all like that. It's called I Hate Being Me. Also a good thing for a blank bumper sticker, Willie, if you've got a second one. It's blank t-shirts that I have.
在酒吧或其他地方做这件事容易得多。我觉得那压力挺大的。不，我们都这样。这叫“我讨厌做我自己”。这也是写在空白汽车贴纸上的好文案，威利，如果你还有第二个的话。那是空白T恤衫，我有。
I Hate Being Me is so true. I Hate Being Ellipses and then on the back just put me. We love you, Jason, we love you. Thank you. I'll tell you who we do love. Taryn Edgerton. Joining us today. You are something else.
“我讨厌做我自己”太真实了。我讨厌做——省略号，然后在背面直接写上“我”。我们爱你，杰森，我们爱你。谢谢。我告诉你们我们爱谁。塔伦·埃哲顿。今天做客我们的节目。你真是不一般啊。
You are something else. Thanks for having me. Anyone who cares in Wales, if you see Gareth Bale, tell him to send me the money. And you know, best of luck with smoke. Smoke, smoke on Apple TV. I can't wait to watch that. When does it come out?
你真是不一般。谢谢你们邀请我。威尔士任何关心此事的人，如果你看到加勒特·贝尔，告诉他把钱给我。还有，你知道的，祝《烟雾迷城》一切顺利。《烟雾迷城》，Apple TV上的《烟雾迷城》。我等不及要看了。它什么时候播？
It comes out on the 27th of June. Day after my birthday. Oh. No way. For my birthday we'll watch it. For Tracy, Sean's birthday is the day he was born. Is that fucking? That's pretty safe to say. Are you registered anywhere, Seanny?
它在6月27日上线。我生日的第二天。噢。不会吧。为了我的生日，我们会看的。说真的，肖恩的生日就是他出生的那一天。这特么不是废话吗？这可以说是个稳妥的推断。你在哪里注册过礼品清单吗，肖尼？
I'll email you. Yeah, yeah, I'm registered. Taron, love you. I love seeing you again. I miss you my friend. Nice to meet you, Taron. Say hi when you come back to LA. Yeah, I will, mate.
我发邮件给你。对，对，我注册了。塔伦，爱你。很高兴再次见到你。我会想念你的，我的朋友。很高兴认识你，塔伦。下次来洛杉矶打个招呼。好的，我会的，伙计。
Take it easy. Pleasure, pleasure. All right, my friend. Thank you very much. Bye, Taron. Bye, you guys. Bye, Taron. Bye, pal. Okay, so anyway, so Taron was amazing. Yeah, it was so good. Yeah, Taron was incredible. And I loved having Taron. Bye, Terrence. Bye, pal. Bye, bye. Okay, so anyway, so Terrence was amazing.
保重。荣幸之至，荣幸之至。好的，我的朋友。非常感谢。再见，塔伦。再见，各位。再见，塔伦。再见，老兄。好了，总之，塔伦太棒了。对，太棒了。对，塔伦简直不可思议。而且我很喜欢有塔伦来做客。再见，特伦斯。再见，老兄。拜拜。好了，总之，特伦斯太棒了。
Yeah, it was so good. Yeah, Terrence was incredible. And I loved having Terrence. It was so good. Oh, you're just trying to get to your bye? You excited about your bye? No, no, but it was just because once he was gone and then I was like the rush to see who was going to talk first.
对，太棒了。对，特伦斯简直不可思议。而且我很喜欢有特伦斯来做客。太棒了。噢，你只是想赶紧说再见吧？你对你的“再见”环节很兴奋吗？不，不，但这只是因为他一走，然后我就在想，接下来会争着看谁先说话。
Look how blessed he is, Sean. I think he did. Did Terrence leave a mark on you well? He did. I liked him a lot. Right? That's a good man. Yeah, I liked him a lot. He's got a great vibe. Yeah
瞧他多有福气啊，肖恩。我想他确实。特伦斯给你留下深刻印象了吗？确实有。我很喜欢他。对吧？这是个好人。对，我很喜欢他。他很有气场。对
Fucking breathing he said he was single, right? Somebody lay me down call a grown-up Call a grown-up No, he that's that's a good-looking male. Hey, another one. I'm just saying. Don't objectify Taron Entreton. He's a good, good guy.
特么的呼吸间他都说他是单身的，对吧？谁来把我放倒，叫个成年人来。叫个成年人来。不，他——那是个长得很帅的男性。嘿，又来一个。我只是随口说说。别把塔伦·埃哲顿给刻板物化了。他是个很好很好的人，
Very, very good guy, great actor. A very smart, good hat on his shoulders, focused. Isn't like, you know, he doesn't seem like he'd fall off the rails in any moment. And he said he's be very low temperature, like very even keeled. Yeah, balanced. Yeah.
非常非常好的人，伟大的演员。一个非常聪明、脑子很清醒、很专注的人。看起来不像是那种随时会出轨的人。而且他说他情绪很稳定，非常沉着冷静。对，很平衡。对。
Not some ninny. Okay. Whales should be proud. I'm sure they are. I'm sure they're beyond proud. So Sean, how's the search going? Oh, good. This Sunday, Scotty and I are going to my friend Kevin's birthday party in Ojai.
才不是什么傻白甜。好吧。威尔士应该为他感到骄傲。我确信他们是的。我确信他们骄傲得不得了。所以肖恩，你的搜寻工作进展得怎么样？噢，很好。这周日，斯科蒂和我准备去奥海（Ojai）参加我朋友凯文的生日派对。
Oh, yes, okay. This is a really long, Yeah, so it's north of here. It's called Ojai, not to be confused with. No way, no fucking way. No way, don't even fucking say that. What are you talking about? What are you talking about?
噢，是的，好吧。这是一个非常长的——对，它在北边。那叫奥海，别跟……弄混了。不可能，绝特么不可能。不可能，连特么都别说那个。你在说什么？你在说什么？
Not to be confused with Sacramento. What are you talking about? Not to be too cold. Old Bond Sacramento. What are you doing? What? Yeah. No, but you know what? Wait, what was that father joke you said at the beginning? The dad joke? That was so good.
别跟萨克拉门托弄混了。你在说什么？别跟……老邦德萨克拉门托。你在干什么？什么？对。不，但你知道吗？等等，你开头说的那个冷笑话是什么来着？那个老爸笑话？太棒了。
The teacher. Yeah, I said what? Oh wait, where is it? Oh yeah. Private tutor. What do you call a teacher who never farts in public? Yeah, private tutor. Private tutor. You know, he did the Rocket Man, right?
那个老师。对，我说的是什么？噢等等，在哪儿呢？噢对。私人导师。你怎么称呼一个从不在公共场合放屁的老师？对，私人家教（私人导师）。你知道的，他演了《火箭人》，对吧？
Which was such a great, and one of my favorite songs ever. Goodbye! Yellow Brick Road! Smart. Less. Smart.ess. SmartLess. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armgerve, Bennett Barbicoe, and Michael Granteri.
那真是一部超棒的电影，而且里面有我最喜欢的歌之一。再见！黄砖路！聪明。无。聪明。无。SmartLess。SmartLess 是由罗布·阿尔默格夫、本特·巴比科和迈克尔·格兰特里 100% 有机手工制作的。
SmartLess. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
SmartLess。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。